now have your attention please well
everyone take their seat please
we take your seats please
ladies and gentlemen we now turn to a
particularly pleasant aspect of this
evening the time when we honor those
reporters who excelled in 1996 and to
look forward to the future to honor the
high-school student who we believe has
the potential to set new and higher
standards into the next century
first to present the scholarship award
named after AP's longtime White House
correspondent Frank Cormier we turn to
Ken Walsh of US News will you please
give him your attention
let me have mr. second
can I have your attention please
thank you
the White House Correspondents
Association scholarship was established
in 1991 and was named in 1994 to honor
the memory of Frank Cormier White House
correspondent for The Associated Press
for two decades the 2000 dollar award
derived from contributions to our
scholarship fund this year is designed
to recognize the accomplishments and
potential of a college-bound high school
senior
this year's recipient was honored
because of her clear academic
achievements excellent journalistic
potential and solid writing ability the
recipients goal is to become an
electrical engineer and lawyer and an
entrepreneur in her own corporation
in our essay for the competition
he travels
thank you for your attention in her
essay for the competition our winner
this year warned of the negative side of
Technology she pointed out that while
new inventions such as the internet and
compact discs make life more interesting
and convenient they also have potential
problems she talked about how people
need to interact more with each other
and not be carried away with technology
so they lose the human connection I'd
like to now at this point present to you
the winner of the White House
Correspondents scholarship in honor of
Frank Cormier for 1997 francesca
mitchell of Ballou high school in
washington
thank you Ken now to present this year's
winners of our arrow annual journalism
awards priest please welcome
Arlene Dillon of CBS Arlene
president mrs. Clinton vice president
mrs. Gore ladies and gentlemen once
again I am honored to present to you
tonight the winners of the three top
awards given to fellow journalists by
the White House Correspondents
Association and two by the congressional
galleries
before I begin I would like to invite
the President and the Vice President up
here to join me and help me present
these awards with you
first let's take a moment to give a hand
to our judges they work tirelessly this
year we had a lot of very qualified
entries their names are in the program I
won't read them all to you but please
take a moment to read them yourselves
Thank You judges
our first award is the Merriman Smith
award this award commemorates the work
of the late Merriman Smith who for many
years was the chief White House
correspondent for UPI and is given for
exceptional presidential coverage under
deadline pressure in the print category
this year's award is given to Ron
Fournier of The Associated Press
Ronn is recognized for his coverage of
the President's second-term cabinet
announcements he worked well into the
early hours of the morning to produce
what the judges called a wire service
exclusive that was right on target in
the broadcast category the award goes to
Merrill liason of National Public Radio
marah's report about a small California
town during the 1996 Clinton campaign
was called an insightful audio portrait
by the judges our second award honors
Aldo Beckman the late White House
correspondent and Washington bureau
chief of the Chicago Tribune it is given
for overall excellence in presidential
coverage this year the award goes to
Todd Purdum of the New York Times
Todd is unanimously recognized by the
judges for his reporting and writing
during 1996 providing and I quote unique
and valuable insight into the
personality of our 42nd president
the third award the Edgar a Poe award
for excellence in covering news coverage
of national and regional significance is
given in honor of our friend and former
Washington correspondent of the New
Orleans times-picayune this year it goes
to byron akka he doe of the Seattle
Times for his investigative series
safety at issue the 737
mr. haka hito persevered in the face of
personal attacks by a corporate giant
and with vast cloud in his own community
the judges called it a story with global
implication a courageous work biron also
received this year's Pulitzer Prize for
beat reporting
now for the award sponsored by the
Congressional press galleries first the
Raymond clapper award named for the
Scripps Howard correspondent killed
while covering World War two first prize
goes to Elizabeth marchek of the
Cleveland Plain Dealer for her report on
the FAA and valujet Airlines
second prize is awarded to Keith Epstein
and bill slow also with the Cleveland
Plain Dealer
for excellent reporting on human medical
experiments
like oh is it like
and finally so worth being a memorial
award for Investigative Reporting of
national significance to the public
interest
this award is once again given to
veronika hito of the seattle times for
safety at issue the 737
ladies and gentlemen the honorees judges
and the board would like to thank you
for recognizing our winners tonight
thank you very much
elsewhere women
the sheriff's here
thank you
Thank You Arlene for your personal photo
op president mrs. Clinton vice president
mr. mrs. Gore distinguished guests in
1971 President Nixon attended this
dinner afterward he sent a memo to his
the White House chief of staff HR
Haldeman it said the dinner was I quote
probably the worst of this type I have
attended he went on to describe the
dinner as a disgusting group drunken
crude and terribly cruel he said that
under absolutely no circumstances would
he ever attend this dinner again in
light of that President Clinton thank
you for coming I hope you're having a
better time than President Nixon
I know my role here tonight talk fast
and get out of the way last year I know
it
last year there was only one person here
who really wanted to hear my remarks
that was my wife Jeannie Johnson tonight
I've expanded my cheerleaders table with
my brothers and sisters some friends my
daughter Emily is out there with our
c-span viewers and I welcome all of them
and I want to take a moment to thank Lu
Bacardi John Woolman and sandy Johnson
for their support mr. president we have
a very impressive audience here tonight
we have most of the senior White House
staff well practically the entire White
House we have cabinet members we've got
members of Congress we've got the
Supreme Court we've got a lot of
Hollywood celebrities and we have a
special minority group in this Hall of
3000 people tonight that's about 30
White House Correspondents
tonight it's time to report to them on
the ambitious three-part program that I
presented last year point one I boldly
said that we should have safe planes as
we fly around the world and covering the
president well a year later we're all
here and our planes didn't Christ
so I say mission accomplished point two
I suggested we should have better food
on Air Force One back in the press cabin
this was a tough one because some people
the photographer's in particular light
the breakfast burritos the beans and
Franks and the baskets of chips but I
persevered anyway about a week after I
launched my campaign the president wrote
a note about it to his staff here's what
he said this is a true story he said
Terry hunts speech Saturday night called
for better food for press on Air Force
One I thought they got what we did
no offense mr. president but we do get
the same food you do I think that was
the problem
the White House came up with a novel way
to solve this problem now the White
House menus carry a message that says
meals prepared aboard Air Force One use
low-fat or no fat ingredients regardless
of what they serve so now we can eat
breakfast burritos without any guilt the
president sent me back a note one flight
when the menu listed pizza and garden
salad right after the no fat disclaimer
he scribbled I have some land out west
I'd like to show you
23 this was a complaint about
presidential motorcade I said the press
vans had fallen so far back in the
motorcade that we weren't in the same
zip code as the president's limousine on
this one
the news isn't so good forget the same
zip code hoax
we're so far back now that our letters
come back stamped return to sender
address unknown so there you have it
success and failure and I raised the
price of this dinner to boot for that
Sarah McClendon chewed me out is only
Sarah can she did so I knew it was time
to step down but I have a worthy
successor
Larry McQuillan who has promised to
remedy all of my shortcomings it's with
a great deal of pleasure that I turn
over the microphone to my colleague from
Reuters Larry McQuillan
you
you know Thank You terror I I've got to
tell you the reception I was just given
now there's a lot nicer than the one I
got the last time I spoke to a big crowd
I wound up getting a call one afternoon
from a friend and he begged me to come
talk to his organization that night it
was really they wanted to hear what I
had to say and I somehow went along with
it and as I was walking across the stage
being introduced the words to inspire
the crowd were unfortunately Helen
Thomas couldn't be with us tonight
actually I just had really have a simple
message I just want to thank you for
participating in this dinner it began
more than 80 years ago with a pretty
simple idea that all of this both
journalists and the people we cover
should remember that while we have
differences we share some ideas in
common - you know it's always hard to
talk for a group is diverse is a bunch
of journalists but I think it's safe to
say that virtually all of us got into
the business because we'd like to make
the world just a little better place and
the point of this dinner is to remind us
that we all share that kind of mission
and goal even if we got some different
ideas on how to get there you know
it's a strange process to become
president of this association you have
to you have to do weird things you have
to be a politician we have a campaign
season that's believe me entirely too
long we have to go out and shake hands
with people listen to them feel their
pain and and and then we go through the
torture of waiting for the election
results I mean you know mr. president I
guess what I'm saying is it if you think
you've got it rough when you face tough
questions at a news conference with
those people on my constituents it's not
easy
actually you know it just occurred to me
mrs. Clinton writes a weekly newspaper
column and she does spend a lot of time
at the White House you know you may want
to look at one of our membership
applications and this is Gordon you
should know that we represent
photographers too and actually mr. vice
president um we have an associate
membership that a lot of a lot of X
journalists find quite popular and now
if I could just say one thing that's a
little bit serious and actually to my
constituents I do have a goal for the
coming year and I not promising it can
be done but I'd like to try it's
improving the conditions in the in the
White House briefing room
you know a colleague of mine recently
likened it to a rundown waiting room at
a Greyhound station it's seriously it's
really being unfair because Greyhound
doesn't deserve that kind of rap and I
must admit another friend worries every
time that James Lee Witt comes in for
fear he may declare it a disaster area
but you know we don't want to move out
of the press area and there and there
isn't a need to the proximity it offers
is essential for us to do our jobs but
but hopefully we can cooperate among
ourselves and with the White House to
make it function better for all of us
and and finally this dinner gives us a
chance to say thanks to the the White
House staff and in particular we all
really appreciate the the effort and and
courtesy that we're treated with every
day by Mike McCurry and Marcia berry and
Lorraine Bowles and and we do appreciate
that
and you know but by the way with just
one more quick thing while Terry really
does love the food on Air Force One I
know he'd be the first one to agree that
we all appreciate just how hard the the
crew on Air Force One and and the crew
that supports the vice president and
first lady how hard they work and we do
appreciate that anyway this is the point
Terry really looks forward to this this
is a sign of our appreciation for all
the hard work that I know you've done in
it and you really have and I I can't
tell you how much I admire it and how
much I'm worried about doing it myself
but at any rate it's it's not a gold
watch but really you don't have enough
plaques and gavels around the house
anyway yeah right
Thank You Larry the thing I like about
this is this means that I'm in the last
moments of my presidency and it's going
to him now it's not my pleasure to turn
to the man this dinner is designed to
honor in its 83 years the White House
Correspondents Association has had but
one toast please join me in that toast
now to the President of the United
States
ladies and gentlemen the president
thank you very much
thank you very much mr. Hart thank you
so much for reading the notes that I
wrote you just like every other
journalist make all my memos public
I
Larry McQuillan Arlene Dylan John
Stewart it will make us glad we came in
a few moments to all by the
distinguished the head table guests and
ladies and gentlemen um I tried to
fulfill Terry hunts agenda his president
those are real notes I wrote him and I
will try to fulfill Larry's agenda I
think it's terrible the conditions in
which the White House press corps labor
it really is it reminds me of nurse
cratchits office and One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest
and it's really a tribute to the
futility of a politician pandering to
the press because you know that was used
to be an indoor swimming pool that
brought great joy to FDR and JFK and
presidents in between Richard Nixon gave
it to you and he got such good press in
return
maybe this is his final revenge the
miserable conditions of it we could
uncover it but let you keep it I could
build a Cabana well you think about it
before I get into my jokes I have some
important serious news senator Lott and
I have broken the gridlock over the
budget a deal now appears eminent
miraculously the 56 billion dollars
thank you the 56 billion dollar gap that
has separated Democrats and Republicans
has been bridged and ladies and
gentlemen we all senator Dole a huge
debt of gratitude
the best part is we don't have to start
playing it back till 2005
that's outside the budget window bigger
tax cuts more money for the Justice
Department whatever just sign up you can
have it you know if I'd known Bob Dole
was that generous I'd invited him over
for coffee
I want to congratulate awardees tonight
um Byron our hero who's come from so far
away and did such good work and then
there are the local winners of Ron
Fournier Marlys and Todd Purdum of
course I'm not familiar with any of your
work but I'm sure it's very good but
this Purdum guy's name sounds familiar
perdón perdón I think I read it in the
engagement announcements recently
Hillary and I congratulate ty and didi
on their marriage next month
you know didi and I started out together
on a little plane in New Hampshire and
we made it all the way the White House
and she sort of straight over to your
side for a while and I was kind of
disappointed now she's getting on a 747
going to Beverly Hills they grow up so
fast nothing now I got another serious
thing I want to talk about something
that I know really you all are on me
about all the time
many of you are distressed that you're
not notified in a timely fashion about
breaking news like my knee breaking and
that's valid and I've been doing some
work to make sure it never happens again
in fact in the spirit of reinventing
government that the vice president has
so indoctrinated me with starting
tonight we've decided to give you
advance notice of upcoming mishaps
mike mccurry has asked me to inform you
of the following while engaging in some
volunteer work tomorrow in philadelphia
i will be on the receiving end of a
painful encounter with a ball-peen
hammer and i will do my best to do it
before your filing deadline at 5:00 on
may 22nd i will be visiting this home of
tiger woods to celebrate his recent
victory in the masters please be advised
there's a loose brick on the patio on
July 8 during the 5th inning of the
all-star game in Cleveland I will
attempt to catch a foul ball from Rafael
Palmeiro stay tuned
look at mark Miller's running that call
his editor now well I know we're here to
honor you tonight
because of the work you do but this
dinner is a pittance compared to the
testament to your profession last week
which opened its doors called the museum
the museum the museum what really
surprised me for any event in Washington
this opening actually got a lot of
favorable press coverage evidently you
journalists have a lot of friends in the
media
but there are a bunch of exhibits I'm
dynasty I want to see the portrait
gallery of unnamed sources
the gergan and shields retrospective the
museum's crowns you'll the Hall of
pundits modeled after the Hall of
Presidents Disneyland
it features mechanized mannequins
mouthing contentious blather
no wait that's the McLaughlin group
there's also an absolutely amazing
collection of historical artifacts
c-span's gavel the gavel edgings of the
Constitutional Convention CNN's very
first crossfire from the left Alexander
Hamilton from the right Aaron Burr topic
gun control there's an actual press
corps travel manifest from stagecoach
one guess what the film they showed was
Fargo the 30 people in the White House
press corps are laughing about there are
artifacts of contemporary Washington
journalism as well there's the stack of
Bibles upon which Joe Kline swore
there's a Johnny Apple's expense reports
a transcript of Anne Rice's interview
with Bob Novak the the contract where
Bob Woodward insists on Robert Redford
being cast as him there's a haunting
photograph from the 1961 White House
Correspondents Dinner of a young Brian
Williams shaking hands adoringly with
Chet Huntley and then there's a whole
wing dedicated to historic scoops for
example did you know that Helen Thomas
broke the story about the Lincoln
Bedroom while Lincoln was still sleeping
however the most important part of the
museum is an exhibit which poses an
elderly fascinating question both
contemporary and historical how would
currently have covered past presidential
administrations have you seen this I
mean this is an incredible thing in the
exhibit everyone in the current press
corps is making fun of Millard
Fillmore's name that's everyone except
Wolf Blitzer David Letterman keeps
calling William Howard Taft tubby and
Teddy Roosevelt old for hours Maureen
Dowd writes a column dismissing the
first presidential election is politics
as usual
sam donaldson makes fun of George
Washington's wooden teeth but completely
ignores the obvious fact that he's
wearing a wig
the New York Times calls for a special
counsel to look into George Washington's
winning campaign in the Revolutionary
War because Lafayette was French
and Barbara Walters asks the father of
our country if you can chop down a tree
any tree at all what kind of tree would
it be
all right now we're gonna tell some
stuff on us you know I know you could
give me grief from time to time but
really I was we work around the clock
trying to help you do your job I mean
really what other administration would
make thousands and thousands of internal
memos and official documents available
for your daily enjoyment but you did
miss a couple of good stories roll it in
boys come here where are they
where are my documents oh here come here
I hope no one's in contempt for ignoring
these
oh this is just a representative sample
you'll have them all tomorrow
here's a memo from Harold Ickes to Leon
Panetta Leon FYI Maxwell House coffee is
on sale this week for 349 a pound
here's a copy of a check we mistakenly
thought was a small campaign
contribution from AT&T turns out that by
caching it we authorized the switz in
our long distance service
here's the memo outlining the DNC's high
donor program it's pretty embarrassing
business class upgrades for airforce one
mr. speaker it could have been you
and let's see here's one for $10,000 you
can have a private meeting with Vice
President Gore to discuss reinventing
government and for $20,000 you don't
have to go
ten
well this is the most embarrassing one
of all from the White House visitor log
last year I can't believe any of you
missed this it seems that during the
period of time when the first lady was
recording her Grammy award-winning album
Milli Vanilli came to the White House 32
times
now I don't know how this got in here
this is a letter of acceptance to
Chelsea saying that she will the from
Chelsea saying that she will attend no
that's privileged
but look the bad news is our only child
is going off to college the good news is
opens up another bedroom
but now look you all know I want to
build a bridge to the future not the
past
I'm interested in the future so I want
you to just forget about the documents
now we know how important technology is
to our future and the White House has
always been the center of new
technological developments ever since
John Adams occupied it there was the
electric lights the telephone the
telegraph the tape recorder
and the clapper and most recently the
computer now just last week the vice
president and I used a computer in the
Oval Office I felt like a kid who first
got to drive he actually let me do some
things on and it's clear that we are
once again at the threshold of a new era
that will forever change the way
President conduct matters at home and
abroad as of this week I have been
working around the clock trying to
balance the budget with Quicken
and I want you to consider this in the
post Cold War era the introduction of
the computer has raised a profound
question whose finger do you want on the
Control Alt Delete button you know what
my favorite button is f to search and
replace I have enjoyed the daily press
clips so much more since I discovered f2
I read them online now and then I search
and replace thanks for showing me that
out
let me after all look your news reports
are just the first rough draft of
history anyway and I'm just doing the f2
thing to do a little editing let's take
some of the news stories you've written
just in the last month F to search for
budget standstill replace with
prosperity at home and peace abroad
it's better isn't it I mean this starts
for beleaguered replace with like an ask
search for independent counsel replace
with the ice-cream man I'll never forget
how I found out about this incredible
device search and replace I walked into
the vice president's office not very
long ago and he was there working on his
computer f to search for Bill Clinton
I
I got there just in time
James Thurber said that Uemura is one of
our greatest and earliest national
resources that has to be preserved at
all cost well I hope we've stayed a
little up tonight and in wristed I thank
you and come here to honor your
indispensable part in our lively 225
year-old experiment and democracy may we
work together so that it continues to
light and lead the world tomorrow I'm
going to Philadelphia where this great
experiment began to open the president's
summit for America's future will gather
there to renew the spirit of service
that built this country each of us must
serve you and your way me and mine you
can start right now by bussing your own
tables and helping with the dishes now
when John finishes I'm going home thanks
and good night
Thank You mr. president the vice
president wants you to explain that
reinventing government joke he wasn't
quite sure what that was all about now
we turn to a veteran of the stand-up
comedy circuit and television Jon
Stewart is considered one of America's
top young comedians he has hosted his
own nighttime talk show for MTV aptly
titled the Jon Stewart Show his recent
television credits include a live one
our HBO comedy special Jon Stewart
Unleavened this fall he appears opposite
Drew Barrymore and Jennifer Beals and
the feature film wishful thinking
there's a lot more about Jon Stewart
that I can tell you but one of the
nicest things is simply this he showed
up when someone else didn't ladies and
gentlemen Jon Stewart
thank you very much mr. president mrs.
Clinton vice president and mrs. Gore
white house correspondents distinguished
guests
before I begin I know there's a lot of
important people here but I've been
sitting up here for about three hours so
if you just excuse me I have to check on
just one quick thing mom good table work
how was the fish dry good portion thank
you for being here she was very excited
to be here I was a little nervous about
taking this gig for what Freese and I do
not know but um she put it all in
perspective
by saying when in your lifetime do you
think you'll ever get the opportunity to
me or even really eat in the same room
as the Karl lubes Dorf so uh
they told me that name would work I
really don't know who he is
which I imagine is about Carl hey you
Carl I know you're thinking the same
thing about me too so I'm really I'm not
very familiar about how things operate
in Washington I don't know the protocol
of these dinners I got some advice from
Washington insiders just sort of help me
along with how my speech was supposed to
go Senator Moynihan said make the speech
bipartisan don't offend senator Lott
said be concise and senator Byrd said no
dogs
apparently that guy just really hates
dogs I Rosie O'Donnell was the
president's first choice to be here this
evening and she withdrew citing a nasty
and brutal confirmation process I wasn't
even the second choice Dennis Miller was
a second choice but he got hung out by
an illegal nanny technicality but isn't
that what the confirmation process is
all about here in Washington weeding out
the truly qualified to get to the truly
available
one more like that and I might get to go
to the Vanity Fair party um are you guys
going to that that's a tough ticket boy
good luck
I was confirmed I don't know if you read
about it last week but I went before the
Joint Select Committee on mandatory
dinners at the Hilton and I have the
transcripts
oddly enough the transcripts from my
confirmation hearing hmm
I really don't do any prescience but
I'll do my best to dramatize the spirit
of what went on in my hearing senator
Helms please just do it
are you now or have you ever been a
card-carrying member of the Don Imus fan
club mr. Stewart uh not card-carrying no
thank you
senator Byrd mr. Stewart were you aware
that during the Peloponnesian War
dogs were utilized mainly as weapons
no I didn't know that are you sure you
don't have a dog yes have you ever
caught a frisbee in your mouth no I have
not
I don't know why he sounds like Charlton
Heston but that's as good as I go
senator Kennedy
mr. Stewart can you tell this committee
the difference between a Rob Roy and a
Manhattan sugar and crushed fruit in the
glass I vote to confirm
I know I know that's an obligatory joke
to be honest with you I love Senator
Kennedy I think that guy's the coolest
although I do think he has kind of an
enormous head um
honestly it doesn't even look like a
head it looks more like a container for
a head
it's just an observation
congressman Patrick Kennedy well they're
giving him a shot on the Joint Select
Committee congressman Patrick Kennedy
mr. Stewart do you like video games
not really
senator Thurmond do you like cheese I do
and finally congressman delay does the
distinguished comedian from New York who
want a piece of me huh Punk
but I am very happy to be here and let
me just say this is the nicest Seder
I've ever been to today is for my people
the Jewish people the sixth night of the
holiday Passover or as Pat Buchanan
refers to it Saturday
oh my god that actually reminds me I
apologize I have an announcement to make
due to a scheduling conflict with a
local convention the Albright bus
mitzvah will now be held in the Coolidge
room congratulations miss Aubrey
she's Jewish now
just trying to welcome her to the team
I think it's great miss Albright can can
find out about her Jewish heritage and
it doesn't really drastically change her
life she can go on with her work and
doing the things she did
whereas when Ralph Reed found out he was
Jewish he had to quit his job so that
was really tough
apparently that didn't fly where he
works I don't uh mystery did quit the
Christian Coalition but Pat Robertson
says the split is amicable and in fact
wishes Ralph's quote Mazel Tov
hello Pat's a little annoyed he has to
change the name of his show to the 699
Club sorry is that there's not McCurry's
job yeah ah I have an announcement right
here thank you very much Terry oh wow
pierre salinger has just announced
he has definitive proof that tonight's
coffee has been replaced by Folgers
crystals apparently as videotape and
chatroom transcripts says it's all gonna
be in his new book if you knew what I
knew it would curl your eyebrows
what happened to Washington books by the
way what is the whole thing now on the
new tell-all insider books whatever
happened to the old-style Washington
books of substance profiles and courage
what I think now we've got help me I'm
locked in the cabinet behind the Oval
Office
well the behind the Oval Office is a
better title than the first title he was
gonna use my name is dick M and I'm a
sexaholic so
guess I'm not going to that party after
all speaking of mazelTov here there are
congratulations in order apparently a
marriage mr. greenspan and andrea
mitchell
we're married that's excellent news miss
Mitchell you must be thrilled I mean in
the drab workaday world of journalism
how can you not be swept off your feet
by the electrifying charisma of a
veteran economist probably had you from
those three romantic words I fight
inflation
I kid mr. Greenspan of course because I
have no investments
honestly I am at your mercy please don't
raise interest rates I'm not kidding I'm
trying to buy an apartment in New York
and I'm at your mercy until mister dole
approves my loan
speaker Gingrich did get a loan from mr.
Dahle $300,000 they say he got a
sweetheart deal but uh I think he ought
to make prompt payments on that mister
dole seems like a pretty tough customer
and I think one guy here on crutches is
enough
capiche
mister dole is trying to actually change
his image from the very gruff one to a
more grandfatherly one apparently the
$300 $300,000 she lent mr. Gingrich came
enclosed in a birthday card which I
thought was really sweet can you have
that a replace and delete thing can i F
to that joke
as mr. Gaines speaker Gingrich is not
even here is he is it I think this might
be his weekend to house it leader
he's back there are a lot of celebrities
here this evening uh it's a tradition of
the Association dinners that actually
began I did some research began at the
first dinner in 1921 when Mary Pickford
came as a guest of John McLaughlin which
I thought was really interesting
Ellen DeGeneres is here a very big
celebrity I keep I commend her courage
actually in coming out with her
sexuality had much personal risk I might
add although I still believe it's an
elaborate ruse to keep Larry King from
hitting on her but uh
sir
apparently he's a flirt
i watch ESPN I have no idea I did see
Ellen's interview with Diane Sawyer and
it was last night and I thought it was
really moving and I thought this was
really interesting she said that her
first experience in that ilk realm in in
that thing was at age 18 with her best
girlfriend and immediately following the
interview Dick Armey introduced
legislation banning same-sex friendships
I blew that when I was a good one too
yeah but all these celebrities are
surely a boon for c-span I would bet
tonight that they are almost sure to
double their viewer
even though we are pre-empting the
regularly scheduled program Blue Goose
the making of a podium
you know we actually had something like
c-span where I used to work only we
called it a security camera
there we go I like c-span it's
mesmerizing kind of like the Yule Log
it's uh I'll tell you what it isn't very
exciting but wait until High Definition
TV hits I have heard that if you watch
c-span on high-definition TV it gives
the illusion that Vice President Gore is
three-dimensional
I cleared that
there are a lot of big issues here on
the table here in Washington right now
there's some debate in Congress about
the FDR memorial I don't know if you're
familiar with this but there's some
interest groups that are concerned with
historical accuracy and they're lobbying
Congress
some say FDR should not be in his
wheelchair for the memorial some say he
should be standing some say he should be
having a cigarette some say not some say
Eleanor's statue should not have fur on
it so they actually did a poll in USA
Today on Friday I guess to give Congress
a sort of a feel for how regular
Americans feel about that issue and the
results are really interesting 8% felt
he should be in the wheelchair 12% said
he should be standing and 80 percent
said pass a budget so
I know that was interesting you got to
nip these people in the bud with the
with the statues and the interest and
the whole thing I've heard it's already
spreading out of the Lincoln Memorial
apparently a group of historical purists
are arguing about the historical
accuracy the Lincoln Memorial
complaining that Lincoln himself was
neither fifty feet tall nor made of
bronze but Washington has always been a
hotbed of social protests I guess the
biggest recent one was the Million Man
March or as many of you probably
remember it that day we called in sick
anyway mr. president I'm sure this has
been a very gratifying yet difficult
year for you it's an honor for me to be
here
I know Kenneth Starr is not here tonight
I think that guy's getting a little
desperate
yesterday he subpoenaed NASA to
investigate why so much money is being
spent on the Hubble telescope
nope nope no nope nope
I was told if I go over my a lot of time
the Peruvian hostage release team was
gonna come in here and take all your
people out hey you know would be a good
thing to get to the end as we approach
the Millennium I guess the real job of
government is to watch out for all the
lunacy that's been going on the closer
we get to the year 2000 the more
lunatics seem to come out of the
woodwork and I'll tell you it's already
happening you know who really scared me
was that crazy cult leader from
California Bob Dornan
so thank you all very much for your time
this has been a great honor for me have
a good night thank you
thank you John before we adjourn to the
many after-dinner receptions being
sponsored by various news organizations
I want to thank some people who have
worked very hard to make this dinner a
success in particular I want to thank
Mike McCurry and Laurie McHugh of the
White House
the chief architect of this dinner the
person who worked the hardest was Julie
Weston one of the sunniest most
efficient people I've ever met she was
terrific
and let me thank Sharon Quarles Rebecca
Krantz
and George pull us this was a huge
undertaking now I ask all of you to
remain seated while Larry McCool and our
new president and steward Powell our new
vice president escort president mrs.
Clinton and vice president mrs. Gore out
of the ballroom we thank them for
attending we thank you all for coming
and we'll see you all again next year
thank you
you